[Music]
in this
we had the training we fought to protect
the weak but training doesn't prepare
you to on someone you used to call
brother
he has left us no other choice if we
don't stop him
there will be nothing left to save
[Music]
at e3 this year we were given a peek at
the trailers for the upcoming year one
episodes the one I'm focusing on in this
video is Episode three which appears to
revolve around the main villain of the
series so far
Aaron kena and how he's become once
again a priority target for the
strategic homeland division we haven't
been given a lot of extra information on
kina in the division two so far so this
announcement was well received by the
community for now while we eagerly wait
for this to be released later on in the
year this is a recap of what Aaron keen
has been up to so far if for some reason
you missed my note on the previous video
this is simply an extended version of
the last one for those of you who are
after a little more if you did watch the
last video you can jump ahead to the
time stamp shown on screen this is just
something new on trying one video for
the short and concise facts only start
in an extended video where I just talk
and talk and talk
Aaron kina had a privileged upbringing
and has never faced real adversity
despite this he has proven through
willpower and intelligence to be able to
overcome any obstacle he faces Aaron
keener enrolled at the Citadel the
Military College of South Carolina after
graduating he joined the military he
served a tour of duty at Camp lemon air
and Djibouti
KYNA used his decision-making skills and
experience in the military to gain
extensive success after leaving the
military he took up a job as a futures
trader on Wall Street the military label
Keener is adaptable and confident he has
been married twice
with both ending in divorce however he
maintains friendly relationships one of
them described keener is too much work
to keep up words theater is very
personable character enabling him to get
others to work together to achieve his
goals as intellect and military
expertise made him a prime candidate for
the strategic homeland division
[Music]
kena was part of the first wave of
division agents to be activated after
the outbreak of the green poison one of
his objectives given by the division was
to secure what would be known as the
dark zone that was being constructed to
contain the infected citizens as
violence and anarchy raged on the
streets of Manhattan keener and his
fellow agents followed mission protocols
to preserve order and maintain the
quarantine
however Sara and the JTF had other plans
they decided to cut their losses and
ordered all forces to pull out of the
dark zone at all costs
Aaron kena the first wave agents and
thousands of infected had been abandoned
left to fend for themselves kena felt
betrayed
during the JTF retreat Aaron was leading
a group of civilians out of the dark
zone when they were ambushed by a group
of ruckus kina sheltered the civilians
in an apartment building and continued
to fend off the overwhelming number of
wreckers he radioed the JTF for
reinforcements but despite explaining
his situation he was denied after a
Molotov cocktail was thrown into the
building everyone was killed
apart from kira who managed to escape
this incident changed kinas perspective
of the federal government and it lifted
disenchanted with his role as a division
agent feeling a great deal of anger and
betrayal it was at this moment when he
decided to withdraw from his mission and
disavow the strategic homeland division
[Music]
as a division agent kena felt a sense of
duty to protect the weak and innocent
but after being denied help and the
civilians under his care were killed by
the Rikers he felt a great deal of anger
towards the government as he believed he
could have saved the civilians and that
the first wave could have saved the dark
zone altogether had the government been
more confident after going rogue his
determination perseverance stays the
same
only his goals and loyalties have
changed kina strongly believes that the
man-made contagion that has been
introduced had created a new reality one
that affected not just the dark zone or
the city of New York or even the United
States but the entire history of the
human species he now believes that rule
and order no longer exists and the only
way to survive is by obtaining power his
first action after turning rogue was
together first way of agents and form a
unit that would work with him to achieve
his goals agents that chose not to LA
with him were killed in cold blood if
division agents could band together as
highly trained individuals with
unmatched tactical skills instead of the
art gear that form an unstoppable force
a force that would be perfectly suited
to seize control of the new world that
was been created in front of them and
this was the event that triggered the
activation of the second wave of
division agents Aaron Kino met up with
Charles bliss the commanding officer of
the last man battalion as the strongest
faction in Manhattan KYNA wanted to make
use of the army to help establish
dominance and bliss was willing to work
with Nikita in order to gain further
advantage of the other factions through
his sh t technology together keener
bliss launched many operations against
the other factions the JTF and the
division one of the most notable being
the bombing of the JT of helicopter that
was carrying the division 2nd wave
commander as well as the majority of the
second wave division agents during this
time Keenan was also running his own
investigation into the dollar flu
outbreak it was around this time that
the second wave discovered several
bodies of the first wave division agents
in several clues and even CCTV footage
they pointed to Aaron kina and his
involvement in the MIAA agents later on
the second wave is tasked with saving
scientist dr. Fatali turn echo from the
Russian consulate but when attempting to
access the panic room
rogue agents working for keen abrecan
kidnapping Tanaka and escaping in a
helicopter
it has discovered that kena had to Neko
taken to the LAV headquarters of the
United Nations building the division in
the JTF stormed the UN building to put
an end to the LMB control over New York
with a secondary objective for finding
Chernenko and kina
however kena was prepared for this he
realizes that the l-anbiya finished and
will be quickly dealt with by the
division so he evacuates with training
co-instructing two of his rogue agents
to stay behind and jam the shd tracking
hardware allowing him a clean getaway
the LMB have driven out of the UN
building and Charles bliss aware of
kinas betrayal is defeated well -
finding his men and allow stand against
the government forces following the lmv
defeat the division learn the cleaners
found Mao slab the creator of the
original smallpox virus kina took the
virus samples a 3d DNA printer and as
many of em hosts research notes that he
could fit into his bag before once again
disappeared at this point in time the
division is well aware of Aaron kinas
activities he is now wanted for high
treason and there's the possibility that
he'd now be registered as a terrorist
with the recent deployment of both the
division and the JTF into the Wyss idea
to help secure the area
numerous smart phone messages have been
found out in the field with five of them
being left behind by Kino himself Kino
states that he decided to broadcast his
location in the Wyss appears in order to
bring all hostile factions into the area
at this stage they all seem to have some
sort of feud with them especially the
LMB this was to ensure that the division
would be brought along in order to keep
their eyes off the prize these messages
revealed that Keenan was indeed in the
West Side Pier hunting down a few things
that he needed for his plans given the
fact that by now according to him both
central and eastern Manhattan had been
picked clean of anything useful to him
his views and feelings towards the
government of the stage have only grown
in intensity he expresses his concerns
and confusion on why the j-tier from the
division are wasting their time on
helping people who aren't worth it and
that they should just be left behind his
last message states that he's now well
and truly gone and also reveals that
he's got his eyes set on not just the
United States but now the world the
final thing that Kino States as they
should any second wave agent who is able
to understand and is willing to join his
mission not to bother looking for
find them when the time is right six
months later multiple audio logs left
behind by Erin keener were recovered in
Washington DC the majority of these were
left behind to further taunt the
division but one of the audio logs talks
about the quarantine in Manhattan and
how it's falling apart
he also indicates that he has since
returned to New York with the telly
around Coney Island and Brooklyn and
this is where the information trail ends
there are still many questions left
unanswered like what has kina been up to
since he left New York why did he return
has he recreated the virus and if so
what does he plan to do hood with the
uprising of the black tusk and the
betrayal of president Ellis it could be
easy to forget that Aaron Keena
still has Russian scientist training Co
and hosts research notes and 3d DNA
printer and several samples of the Dola
flu virus and his whereabouts are still
unknown the black tusk had been around
since the early days of the outbreak and
had been hiding away pulling strings to
assist in the spread of the virus and
the downfall of the United States
government their employers have a goal
of establishing a new dynasty in place
of the old one president Ellis mater's
and tensions known moments before the
full invasion of the black tusk was
released into Washington DC
[Music]
let's get it for Saints will hold in a
tidal basin until I get heard from the
boss
why Burt this is your baby now take good
care of it
understood nothing gets near this
container not even a buckin squirrel you
got me understood
give me that satellite phone I want to
share the news myself
go on give me your phone there's a huge
amount of speculation out there that the
fact that Aaron kina is in fact working
with the black tusk or could even be
their employer but given the massive
financial cost and the fact that their
employers have ties in the US government
this doesn't seem likely as far as
working with them goes it does sit a
little closer to the goals he has in
mind
thanks to Ellis the black tusk now have
the antivirals but all our cure if Tina
wants to be working with them this would
act in his favor he has the ingredients
to recreate the virus stronger and more
efficient than ever and the antivirals
could have removed any sort of leverage
he has but this doesn't quite sit right
with me the black tusk have been around
since before kina had truly turned on
the government and he seemed like a
legitimately good candidate for the
division and absolutely had the
intentions of helping the US public it
also doesn't really explain why Keener's
now returned to New York it is possible
that the black tusk found him and worked
on the psychological weaknesses during
that time filled betrayed in order to
have them do their bidding but the still
doesn't quite fit into his character
keener is the smartest man in the room
and he has no problems with leading
everyone knows it's true that could be
playing him or is it the other way
around
is he letting them feel this way while
carrying out his own plans that way the
division being kept busy and he's free
to come and go as he pleases
over and over again this has brought up
with looking into the origins of the
hunters that they are somehow connected
with Aaron kena it makes sense they were
first known to us in the dark zone when
trying to extract the antiviral so
they've since led to a cure of the
dollar flu and the dark zone was more or
less under kinas control at that point
but since then there have been some
other odd actions from hunters that have
led to further suspicion in one of the
earlier side missions in DC the division
is tasked with finding agent inputs and
agent just as strong and competent as we
are agent Edwards was not just killed by
a hunter but was strung up for us to
find this hunter was sending a message a
message made for us much like the other
hunters he knew our tactics and
technology and much like Edwards he
overpowered us except this time he let
us live and then disappeared without a
trace
why to strike fear into the division
ranks Woodard he Keena see potential in
us this could have just been a show of
power to a system in recruiting us to
his calls later on this could also
explain what the other hunters are less
willing to engage us in DC they've been
lift instructions to leave us alone for
now a cool idea and even answers a few
other questions regarding the hunters
but it just doesn't feel like kinas
style sure kina could have killed
Edwards but as far as stringing him up
to make a statement no that doesn't feel
quite right kina absolutely likes to
play games
Perez amor from a psychological
standpoint he is an intelligent and
focused agent and he prides himself on
knowing what is important and being able
to keep his eye on the goal his games
are more about throwing you off scent if
Keenan was going to play a game it would
be more of mean to one and he would be
sure he had the winning hand Tina finds
victory and winner in a firefight before
the first bullet is shot
maybe just maybe what we've seen in the
story is a hundred percent on track with
what has been happening I know this
probably sounds a little weird can refer
a channel at this we're from time to
time I like to throw out outrageous
ideas and conspiracy theories Erin
keener is a division agent who lost his
way after feeling betrayed by his
government early on in the outbreak
he has since found ultimate power
through the abduction of Vitelli and
finding of Amherst notes DNA printer and
virus samples at this point he's just
trying to boost his ranks through
recruiting as many division agents as
possible as in his words they are highly
trained individuals with unmatched
tactical skills in state-of-the-art gear
they form an unstoppable force a force
that would be perfectly suited to seize
control of the new world that's been
created in front of them with that in
mind think about the messages he's left
for us in DC what if these weren't for
us what if these were actually left for
agent Kelso kina has no idea who we are
we're new to the area and remember that
our agents aren't the same ones that we
had in New York Kelso herself already
acts a little odd from the glares she
gives Ellis to the weird way she reacts
in some scenes something doesn't quite
sit right with her also keep in mind
that Kelso is the most senior of all
agents in DC and maybe she's already
writing a fine line as far as whether to
disavow the division or not she wants to
build a new America in line with what
Keener is proposing but doesn't want to
fully cross that line and become an
enemy of the country she reached out to
kina because she liked the idea of what
he wanted to accomplish but she isn't
ready to go this far I really have very
little to back this one up and it
certainly isn't a popular opinion out in
the community but based on the
interactions were had with kina and the
way he hasn't really done too much since
leaving New York even though he has all
the ingredients that he needs to create
chaos on a mass scale
I still feel there's the possibility
that Erin keener could somehow be the
hero that we all need further down the
line except maybe more of an antihero
sure he's done some pretty horrible
things in fact the list just keeps
growing he's killed JTF first and second
wave division agents
he's worked alongside enemies of the
country like the last man battalion
kidnapping theft obstruction of the
official investigation and the list goes
on but what if he found out about the
corruption
long before we did what if he knew of
the black tusks impending invasion and
the fact that the White House staff had
been compromised he does always seem to
be a few steps ahead of us what if
everything he's been doing up until now
has been in preparation for fighting
back against the force that has deemed
themselves is the New World Order when
you look at his list of crimes the
majority of the Americans the government
itself yes he's an egotistical maniac
and yes he loves leading everyone know
how smart he is but I still feel that
this could be a possible twist that the
story could take but we won't truly know
until episode 3 is released even then we
could be taken down a completely
different rabbit hole in our search for
the ever elusive rogue of ROK's Arron
kina keener is always several steps
ahead of us he could be long gone from
the area or the division could be
falling straight into a trap kina only
gets found when he wants to be found
what are we about to walk into thank you
very much for watching I hope you've
enjoyed this and I'll catch you in the
next one
Cheers
[Music]
[Music]
in this time